en patience l'instauration des congés
payés c'était en 1936 il y a 60 ans pour
s'en souvenir les villes de
Viry-Châtillon et d'Athis-Mons dans la
région parisienne organisée un voyage à
la mer à Fécamp mais l'animingo et
Jean-Yves Perrin
un gros sac à dos pour une journée bien
courte direction Fécamp une journée à la
mer qui prend des airs d'anniversaire
manière pour 400 banlieusards de fêter
60 ans de congés payés ça nous permet
d'avoir une journée de détente et comme
on part pas en vacances
ça me permet à ma fille de voir un peu
la merde on est dans les cités toute
l'année donc ça ça nous fait du bien
quand même
les moins jeunes eux se souviennent de
leur premier voyage pour Jean Masclet
c'était en 38 avec ses parents il y en
avait pas avant
il partait comme ça en vélo à droite à
gauche mais cette épouse
permettre d'aller au bord de la mer
comme on était à Paris
c'était c'était merveilleux
juillet 36 l'encre des accords de
Matignon est à peine sèche les plages
sont prises d'assaut le Front populaire
vient d'attribuer deux semaines de
congés payés à tous les salariés allez
respirez aujourd'hui à Fécamp l'air
était ubis mais pour ses vacanciers d'un
jour il fallait profiter de la moindre
occasion
oui je m'amuse il y a le soleil mais le
truc il est fort maman il doit être
chaud juste un petit bout de bonheur non
la campagne